well the right-wing boycott may be
actually working Bud Light is no longer
the top selling beer in the United
States of America it has been surpassed
by the Mexican lager Modelo Especial or
Modelo as we might say in Spanish this
is a reminder to those on the left these
sorts of public activism campaigns
actually can work now I it's really hard
for me to care about Bud Light it is
such a terrible beer I've been
unofficially boycotting Bud Light for
like 17 years uh because it's just a
terrible beer I never drank it before I
don't I don't drink it now but there is
an interesting activism story here which
is
the boycotts that the right claims to
oppose
actually can be effective let's not
allow only the right to use the tool
they claim to oppose